the GOP s latest plan for health care is
now on life support Senate Republicans
are in a rush to pass a bill to repeal
the Affordable Health Care Act by
September 30th and just like their last
effort it appears basically doomed by a
Kino in their own party Senator John
McCain has once again rejected the GOP
plan and now Republicans once again
cannot afford to lose another vote Paula
Reid is traveling with the president in
New Jersey Paula good morning good
morning the president is not pleased
with Senator John McCain at a campaign
rally last night in Alabama he blasted
the senator for undermining one of the
president's biggest legislative
priorities since taking office
he's also been tweeting this morning
about McCain saying that he campaigned
on repeal and replace that he has let
Arizona down honestly that was a
horrible horrible thing that happened to
the Republican Party at a rally for
Republican Senate candidate Luther
Strange president Trump took aim at
Senator John McCain for opposing the
latest GOP attempt to repeal Obamacare
John McCain if you look at his campaign
his last campaign was all about repeal
and replace repeal and replace so he
decided to do something different and
that's fine and I say we still have a
chance the crowd booed at the mention of
the Arizona senators name
it's got to be done in the in the normal
process that was McCain's explanation
when he voted no on the last healthcare
bill on Friday he had similar reasoning
saying he could not in good conscience
vote for the Graham Cassidy proposal I
believe we could do better working
together Republicans and Democrats the
Graham Cassidy bill would block grant
some of Obamacare's funds to the state
so they could set up their own coverage
but independent analysis shows the bill
would slash federal health care funding
to 34 states and DC most of them states
that expanded Medicaid under Obamacare
five states stand to lose 30 percent or
more McCain joins Kentucky Senator Rand
Paul as the two confirmed no votes in
the Republican Party GOP leaders can't
afford to lose another vote and still
pass the Senate Senator Susan Collins
and Lisa Murkowski to Republicans who
helped kill the last attempt are both
wavering in their support vice president
Mike Pence appeared at the White House
with the governor of Maine on Friday
where he made a direct appeal to Senator
Collins this is not just a fresh start
for America on health care reform but
it's also a fresh start for Maine
senator Collins appears to be leaning
know at this point based on what this
plan would do to Medicaid recipients and
people with pre-existing conditions if
she votes no the plan will fail Paula
we're hearing some news also about what
we know as the travel ban
that's president Trump's ban on citizens
from six mostly Muslim countries it's
set to expire so what are we learning
about a possible replacement we know the
administration is considering new
restrictions on approximately a dozen
countries that they believe just don't
do enough to prevent terrorists and
other criminals from coming to the u.s.
now we don't know specifically which
countries this would apply to but that
could be announced and even implemented
as soon as this weekend you know Paula
Reid thank you very much